ARIZONA.
THE STORY CONTINUES FROM
NEW YORK TOMORROW
>> GOOD EVENING.
THERE WAS A TIME NOT TOO LONG
AGO WHEN IF YOU WANTED TO COMMIT
TREASON, YOU HAD TO WORK FOR IT.
OR
YOU WOULD SET UP A SHORTWAVE
RADIO TRANSMITTER IN YOUR
BASEMENT AND CALL-IN TROOP
MOVEMENTS.
THAT'S HOW PEOPLE USED TO BETRAY
THEIR COUNTRY.
THE STANDARDS ARE LOWER NOW.
ACCORDING TO DEMOCRATS
DONALD TRUMP COMMITTED TREASON
MERELY BY ANSWERING A
HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION.
HERE'S HOW IT HAPPENED.
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS ASKED THE
PRESIDENT WHAT HE MIGHT DO IF A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT OFFERED HIS
CAMPAIGN DAMAGING INFORMATION
ABOUT ONE OF HIS OPPONENTS.
HERE IS HOW THE PRESIDENT
RESPONDED.
>> YOUR CAMPAIGN THIS TIME
AROUND, FOREIGNERS, IF RUSSIA OR
CHINA OFFERS YOU INFORMATION.
SHOULD THEY CALL THE FBI?
>> I THINK IF YOU DO BOTH.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO LISTEN.
IF SOMEBODY CALLED FROM A
COUNTRY, NORWAY, WE HAVE
INFORMATION ON YOUR OPPONENT,
OH, I THINK I WANT TO HEAR IT.
>> YOU WANT THAT KIND OF
INTERFERENCE IN OUR ELECTION >>
HERE IS THE SCENARIO.
NORWAY CALLS AND TELLS YOU
SOMETHING EMBARRASSING ABOUT
BETO O'ROURKE.
MAYBE HE WEARS A WIG OR MAYBE
THOSE BOBBY KENNEDY TEETH OF HIM
OUR DENTURES.
WHO KNOWS.
BUT YOU'RE HAPPY TO HEAR IT NO
MATTER WHAT IT IS BECAUSE WHY
WOULDN'T YOU BE.
PLUS IT'S KIND OF AMUSING.
BIG MISTAKE.
GUESS WHAT.
YOU JUST COMMITTED TREASON.
A DEATH PENALTY OFFENSE.
ACCEPTING ASSISTANCE FROM A
HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER LIKE
RUSSIA.
IT'S TREASONOUS BEHAVIOR.
WHAT DONALD TRUMP SAID IS
UN-AMERICAN, UNPATRIOTIC AND
UNBELIEVABLE.
GO TO MARS, GO TO THE MOON.
HE OUGHT TO GO TO THE MOON.
RALPH GRANDON OUGHT TO SEND >>
THE ANSWER UNDERSCORES THE
IMPORTANCE.
>> EVERYBODY SHOULD BE APPALLED
BY WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID LAST
NIGHT.
>> YOU KNOW YOU'VE REACHED A
MOMENT OF MAXIMUM RIDICULOUSNESS
WHEN THE PEOPLE WHO REFLECTIVELY
SIDE WITH THE GOVERNMENT OF
GUATEMALA OVER OUR OWN CITIZENS
TO
DECIDE TO TELL YOU WHAT'S
UNPATRIOTIC.
HILARIOUS.
IF YOU THINK THAT REACTION IS
HYSTERICAL, WAIT TILL YOU SEE
HOW THE TALKING HEAD COMMUNITY
RESPONSE.
PETER PANDEMONIUM.
>> HE SET STRAIGHT OR TO THE
PILLARS OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> I HAVE RUN OUT OF ADJECTIVES
TO REACT, DESCRIBED THE REACTION
TO THIS.
>> OF ANY OTHER PRESIDENT HAD
SAID ANYTHING RESEMBLING THIS.
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS WOULD'VE
UNDERSTANDABLY CALLED HIM A
TRAITOR.
>> IT'S UNTHINKABLE WHAT HE SAI
SAID.
>> THIS IS THE DEFINITION OF
COLLUSION.
>> I THINK IT IS TREASONOUS,
COMPROMISING, DANGEROUS.
I THINK IT'S WRONG.
IT'S ILLEGAL.
>> Tucker: DANGEROUS, WRONG,
ILLEGAL.
IN A WORD, TREASON.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS WHEN YOU TAKE
DAMAGING INFORMATION ABOUT A
POLITICAL OPPONENT FROM
FOREIGNERS.
OKAY, JUST SO WE'RE CLEAR ON THE
TERMS.
WAIT A SECOND.
ARE WE SURE WERE COMPARABLE WITH
THIS NEW DEFINITION.
IT SEEMS LIKE YOU MIGHT HAVE
SOME UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
SOME OF THE VERY PEOPLE MAKING
RED-FACED ACCUSATIONS OF TREASON
APPEAR BY THEIR OWN STANDARD TO
HAVE COMMITTED TREASON
THEMSELVES.
CONSIDER THE TRUMP DOSSIER.
EVERYBODY IN WASHINGTON READ THE
TRUMP DOSSIER.
JOHN McCAIN'S STAFF MADE
CERTAIN OF THAT.
OUR INTELLIGENCE SERVICES USED
IT TO JUSTIFY EXTENSIVE SPYING.
HERE'S THE THING ABOUT THE
DOSSIER.
IT WASN'T AMERICAN.
OUR AGENCIES, THE CIA, FBI, THEY
DID NOT COMPILE THE DOSSIER.
THE DOSSIER CAME FROM A MAN
CALLED CHRISTOPHER STEELE,
LONGTIME EMPLOYEE OF BRITISH
INTELLIGENCE.
IN OTHER WORDS, A FOREIGN
OPERATIVE.
INFORMATION THAT FORMED THE
BASIS OF THE DOSSIER DIDN'T COME
FROM THIS COUNTRY.
IT CAME FROM FOREIGNERS,
RUSSIANS.
EVERYBODY KNEW THIS AT THE TIME.
CHRISTOPHER STEELE SAID SO AT
THE TIME.
HERE IS A TWEET FROM
HILLARY CLINTON'S PRESS
SECRETARY.
"I REGRET I DIDN'T KNOW ABOUT
CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S HIRING BY
THE HILLARY CAMPAIGN.
ELECTION.
IF I'D KNOWN, I WOULD'VE
VOLUNTEERED TO GO TO EUROPE AND
TRY TO HELP HIM."
HE WENT ON TO SAY THAT THE
HILLARY CAMPAIGN WAS PROUD TO
GET OPPOSITION RESEARCH FROM
FOREIGNERS.
"I PROBABLY WOULD HAVE
VOLUNTEERED TO GO TO EUROPE
MYSELF TO TRYING TO VERIFY, IF
IT WOULD HAVE HELPED GET MORE
THIS OUT THERE BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
WHEN HE SAYS THIS, HE'S
REFERRING TO SALACIOUS DIRT FROM
RUSSIANS.
SO BY THOSE STANDARDS, IT'S
ANTI-AMERICAN.
IT'S TREASON.
YET BRIAN FALLON IS NOT BEHIND
BARS TONIGHT.
HE'S NEVER BEEN CHARGED WITH
TREASON OR ANYTHING ELSE.
NOBODY ON HILLARY CLINTON'S
CAMPAIGN HAS.
THEY ARE STILL WALKING.
DESPITE BEING, AND WE ARE
QUOTING MSNBC, "TRAITORS TO THE
PILLAR OF OUR DEMOCRACY,"
WHATEVER THE HELL THAT MEANS.
MAYBE THEY HAVE MOVED ONTO
LOBBYING FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS.